ccsd parents getting a chance to ask
superintendent
dr jesus jara about a number of concerns
including vaccine rollout
the trending downward of covet cases in
the county and students mental health
the q a session part of a series with dr
jarrah hosted by the ccsd parents
facebook group
pre-k to third grade students returned
to campus march first on a hybrid basis
but no timeline has been publicly
announced for students
between fourth grade and high school
jarrah addressed a possible return for
older students
there is a plan um something that we've
been working on since wednesday when the
governor's office released uh
the restriction and you know i want to
work with the board as
i always do and make sure that we
communicate that as soon as it's
finalized
jarrah address working towards spring
sports saying ccsd would have to
contract
out for weekly covid testing for student
athletes if they return
he also touched upon the health
preparations made within schools
including changing filters in the use of
ionization
dr jarrah stressed the importance of
communication from grading to attendance
policies
and the need for all families to be well
informed about their
child's cohort assignment what